[Musik]
der landkreis rhön grabfeld franken
nördliches bayern
hier gibt es viel natur viel frische
luft und eine geschichte über windräder
die klein sein und viel strom liefern
sollten
wahnsinn katastrophe machen
aber von vorn das neue theater beginnt
mit zwei einheimischen jürgen roth und
harald schwartz treue csu-mitglieder
2010 planen die beiden einen windpark
2014 wird er genehmigt windkraftgegner
klagen dagegen und zeit vergeht
inzwischen gibt es bessere technik und
genau das wird zum problem
windräder neuer bauart sind kleiner und
effektiver
sie liefern 20 prozent mehr energie aber
dürfen die neuen kleinen stadt der alten
größeren auch gebaut werden
windkraftgegner verklagen nun den staat
bayern
der hätte keine genehmigung erteilen
dürfen für die neue technik bereits
laufende bauarbeiten für neue fundamente
werden gerichtlich gestoppt und im
vergangenen sommer entscheidet der
bayerische landtag mit csu mehrheit nein
die neuen windräder dürfen nicht gebaut
werden obwohl sie kleiner und
effizienter sind dabei hatte die
bayerische landesregierung den wind
bauen dort signalisiert alles wird gut
wir waren erst einmal maßlos enttäuscht
dass die csu ihre zusagen nicht gehalten
hat frontal 21 hat darüber im
vergangenen jahr berichtet jetzt
besuchen wir wülfershausen ein
nachbarort des geplanten windparks
wolfgang seifert ist der bürgermeister
csu er kann die entscheidung seiner
parteifreunde im landtag kaum fassen als
ich gedacht habe ich war nicht sprachlos
erst mal gesagt wie kann man sich so
etwas antun
warum sprechen die apa nicht mit uns
fortgeführt kapital ohne ende in die
entscheidung des landtags besiegelt über
fünf millionen euro schaden für die
bauherren doch jürgen roth und harald
schwarz die treuen csu mitglieder wollen
sich nicht zum narren machen und so geht
die geschichte weiter
wir haben dann einen käufer für das
projekt gesucht der die möglichkeit hat
dieses projekt mit den veralteten
anlagen umzusetzen
und das klappt ein neuer betreiber kauft
den kompletten windpark und von drei
wochen rollen seine packen jetzt
passiert dass die alten fundamente jetzt
wieder zurückgebaut werden müssen und
neue fundamente für die erste
genehmigung für veraltete technologie
jetzt errichtet werden also erst abriss
bereits gegossener fundamente die für
die kleineren effizienteren windräder
gedacht waren und dann neubau von
fundament für größere veraltete
windräder und zwar weil nur die
genehmigt worden sind alles ist
eingetreten was ich mir zwar nicht
erhofft hatte aber ist in der
bananenrepublik wir fragen nach bei
steffen vogel
es ist sein wahlkreis er ist
landtagsabgeordneter der csu
warum hat ihre fraktion im letzten
sommer sich entschieden diese anlagen
nicht zu retten die möglichkeit hätte
bestanden
möglicherweise hätte die möglichkeit
bestanden wir haben uns zur wahrung des
rechtsstaatsprinzip und der
gewaltenteilung entschieden
das heißt wie es in der festen
überzeugung dass der gesetzgeber nicht
rückwirkend in ein laufendes
gerichtsverfahren eingreifen kann zu
seinen eigenen gunsten der
genehmigungsbehörde und beklagter war in
dem gerichtsverfahren vor dem
bayerischen verwaltungsgerichtshof der
freistaat bayern und der landtag kann
nicht rückwirkend zu seinen eigenen
gunsten der rechtslage ändern wenn sie
diese aussage ist komplett falsch
die bayerische staatsregierung hat
nämlich genau das gemacht nachträglich
die bayerischen bauern nun geändert aber
nur für die bereits fertiggestellten
anlagen das ist verrückte windpark
genehmigungs bürokratie sind die grünen
überzeugt mit nur drei zusätzlichen
worten im gesetzestext zur bayerischen
bauordnung hätte man auch die anlagen
retten können die geht entweder in
planung waren oder sich im bau
befindlich waren es wäre möglich gewesen
wenn die csu hier nur gewollt hätte
die csu hat nicht gewollt und damit
leben müssen nachbarn des windparks
sowie bauern seien bio hof liegt genau
neben an
er findet den windpark grundsätzlich
okay nur warum er jetzt größere türme
vor die tür gesetzt bekommt das
versteckte nicht der landtag hat ja
gewisse bürokratische entscheidungen
getroffen und somit gegen sich die
praxis und ich bin der meinung es sollte
die das bürokratische dem menschen
dienen und nicht umgekehrt der mensch
das opfer seien von bürokratie der
mensch als opfer der bürokratie einen an
theater aus bayern